shanghai vient de présenter son nouveau
smartphone le mx3 et x3 fait plusieurs
promesses
celui d'avoir un grand écran sans
encoches avec une énorme zone utile plus
de 93% la face avant qui occupé par
l'écran d'écran de qualité du oled
il fait la promesse d'une performance de
dingue avec instinct dragon 845 jusqu'à
10 gigas de ram elle s'est aussi la
promesse d'un excellent appareil photo
pour réussir vos photos donc ce qu'on va
faire aujourd'hui c'est qu'on va
regarder un peu ces différentes - d'un
côté technique voir un petit peu se
cache sous le capot de ce mix 3 en mx3
qu on devrait découvrir et prendre en
main un peu plus tard il y aura une
annonce qui sera fait en europe donc
rester tranquille rassurez vous on en
reparlera du mx3 pour l'instant on va
faire un petit peu le portrait robot
voir un peu ce qu'estime x3 qu'elle peut
faire avec
est ce qu'il est intéressant est ce qu
il a des points faibles pour qu'on va
regarder ça juste après ça
[Musique]
si vous avez l'habitude de suivre mes
vidéos vous aura pas échappé que j'aime
bien la marque chez lui parce que je
trouve que c'est une marque qui est
vraiment le vrai comment dire c'est une
marque qui va dans le sens du
consommateur proposer des technologies
actuelles à des prix défiant toute
concurrence et c'est vraiment ça l'idée
le chiot me pas plus de 5% de marge
c'est l'europe politique donc ce qui
fait qu'ils sont vraiment extrêmement
agressif par rapport à un domaine qui
est extrêmement concurrentiel
vous avez vu si vous vous intéressez au
domaine il ya de plus en plus de marques
qui sont arrivés cette année ça n'a pas
fini ça va continuer ça devient un peu
beaucoup des fois un peu trop on a un
peu de mal à se repérer et à savoir
quels produits achetés et là ce qui est
vraiment intéressant sac avec céline x3
on voit qu'ils viennent un peu marcher
sur les plates-bandes du vivonne ex du
finepix dopo l idée c'est effectivement
d'avoir un smartphone sans encoches on
sait qu effectivement set en poche elle
divise beaucoup depuis l'année dernière
la du coup pas d'encoches à la
différence de smartphones un peu plus
standard où on va retrouver une grande
bande noire en haut une grande bande
noire emballe il n'y a pas du tout de
bandes noires un léger contours légère
légère petite bande en bas pour des
questions purement technique mais
franchement quasiment pas donc l'idée un
peu de ce smartphone c'est de se dire ok
il ya un grand écran il n'y a pas de
gauche
y'a rien qui vient vous embêtez pas
d'appareil photo pas de capteur pad
haut-parleurs rien juste un écran en
avant alors où sont passés ces appareils
photo et comme ce que vous avez sur le
haut pont félix vous avez un petit
tiroir qui vient sortir alors qu'il sort
de façon mécanique motorisés sur le
finepix là c'est manuel vous preniez
votre smartphone vous poussez l'appareil
photo sort vous poussez vous refermez
ils vont tous à andré comptons prendre
en main d'ici quelques temps mais en
tout cas il ya un côté assez ingénieux à
côté chez aussi aux freenautes s'achever
le détail elle attend donc tu t'en vas
commencer par le côté un petit peu
spécifications techniques ne m'en voulez
pas gêner note j'ai pas eu le temps de
tout apprendre par coeur je regarde un
petit peu ce matin ce qui se disait
alors en termes de dimensions je sens
martin qui fait 157 par 75 par huit un
peu plus de 8 mm d'épaisseur et que je
trouve que son papier un peu lourd à
voir lorsque je l'aurais dans la main il
fait 218 g tout ça on le vérifiera
bientôt rassurez vous le dise
c'est un design bord à bord à l'arrière
vous avez un dos en céramique qui permet
la recharge par induction donc ça aussi
c'est pas mal on est dans les critères
actuels et avec le fameux tiroir
coulissant qui peut coulisser jusqu'à
300 mille fois en tout cas c'est ce que
nous annonce iommi ils appellent ça le
magnétique powerslide or je suppose
qu'il a un côté un peu aimante et pour
pas que ce ballet goût de retourner à
l'envers donc vous le poussez island où
vont tous dans l'autre sens il se ferme
côté magnétique est monté tout cas sur
le papier ça a l'air assez séduisant
vous avez un écran oled de 6,39 pouces
avec un écran qui occupent 93 5 4% de la
face avant pour être très précis un
ratio de 19 points 5/9 une définition en
full hd plus de 2340 par 1080 pixels et
403 ppp voilà ça c'est pour l'écran donc
écran en tout cas qui sur le papier a
l'air très séduisant et en connaissant
la qualité des produits chez oh oui je
pense pas du tout contre déçu là dessus
on maintenant on va s'intéresser à la
partie photo vidéo parce que ceux-ci un
point qui a été mis en avant par shiomi
on retrouve à l'avant une double caméra
vous avez une sony enix 576 24
mégapixels plus une autre caméra de 2
mégapixels alors être 2 mégapixels
servira pour les faits évoqués pour
votre profondeur de champ lorsque vous
allez faire des photos en mode portrait
on a la technologie super pixels à 1.8
micro capteurs qui va capter beaucoup
plus de luminosité et ça pour les photos
en faible luminosité pour les photos de
nuit c'est vraiment top
et vous avez également un flash qui est
présent à l'avant alors à l'arrière vous
avez un double capteur deux fois 12
mégapixels un capteur sony mx360 3 avec
une ouverture de f 1.8 donc normalement
en tout cas excellent en faible
luminosité et un deuxième capteur c'est
un tel objectif 12 mégapixels avec une
ouverture de f 2.4 qui permettra d'avoir
un zoom optique x 2 ça c'est plutôt cool
vous avez
pour le capteur principal un large
pixels de 1.4 micromètres vous avez la
stabilisation sur quatre axes vous avez
la reconnaissance de scène grâce à
l'intelligence artificielle et vous avez
bien évidemment toujours ce fameux mode
portrait côté vidéo et ce qui est plutôt
intéressant pour filmer en 4k jusqu'à 60
images par seconde et shlomi nous a
rajouté du slow motion du super slow
motion à 960 images par seconde en 1080p
donc ça aussi c'est un point qui en tout
cas son papier est assez positif
tout ça bien sûr on reverra plus tard
lors des phases de test où la vie doute
à faire une seule chose c'est à vous
abonner puis on reste connectés bon et
la performance dans tout ça parce que
malgré tout avoir un smartphone quelle
belle image d'homme à l'écran c'est bien
mais la performance c'est aussi
important en performance vous allez
aujourd'hui en tout cas ce qui se fait
de mieux
du côté de chez qualcomm vous avez un
stade dragon 845 qui sera dispo soit en
s'y giga de ram soit en 8 giga da soit
carrément en 10 gigas de ram c'est juste
hallucinant
vous avez deux capacités de stockage
soit du 128 giga soit 256 giga il ya du
nfc intérieur en bluetooth 5.0 après il
ya plein de petites choses surtout c'est
un smartphone qui sera le tout premier
en europe à intégrer la 5 gigas dans la
5g on n'y est pas encore du côté de
l'asie sont vraiment en avance par
rapport à nous donc en tout cas sur le
papier c'est plutôt cool et moi que
c'est vraiment une vraie volonté de la
partie xiaomi d'être à la pointe en
termes de techno de ne pas se laisser
dépasser par la concurrence et ça aussi
c'est un point très positif
en plus de ça vous êtes un chargeur sans
fil rapide à l'intérieur de 10 watts
directement inclus dans votre boîte ça
aussi c'est plutôt bien pour l'instant
c'est un produit dont on a absous venez
par l'aveu n'est pas là on se rapproche
doucement se rapproche ça c'est plus
intime
c'est un smartphone pour l'instant on
n'a absolument aucune date de
commercialisation en europe
il va venir il va arriver le mx3 c'est
un peu le le fleuron de chez chuo mido
qui va arriver d'ici quelques temps
quand il sera présenté je vous en
parlerai davantage en prendre en main et
testera pas mal de choses en secours à
plus de tous les côtés en tout cas ce
qu'il spolie tout de suite sans marchés
asiatiques
c'est du sig a drame plus 128 go de
stockage on va faire la conversion sera
à peu près à 420 euros hors taxes en
couleur noire
la version 8 gigas de ram plus 128 go de
stockage à peu près 450 euros hors taxes
en couleurs noir bleu
et puis un vert émeraude et une version
spéciale qu'ils appellent la version
cité interdite qui a un bleu saphir à
l'arrière qui est très jolie artiste
c'est en tout cas une version surboosté
avec 10 gigas de ram 256 go de stockage
qui pour avoir un tarif avoisinant les
510 euros hors taxes je suis pas sûr
qu'à boire 10 gigas de ram dans un
smartphone vous en ayez réellement
besoin l'impression que c'est un peu une
course à l'échalote pour avoir les plus
grands spec par rapport à la concurrence
10 gigas de ram dans un smartphone je
sais pas ce que vous allez on faire
alors on peut se dire peut-être pour des
jeux où il nous faut un truc hyper
puissants d'un côté je suis pas sûr
qu'on a un taux de rafraîchissement de
l'image là dessus du die peut-être dû 60
hertz probablement pas dû s'en va
ailleurs je ne me crois pas en tout cas
donc je vois pas ce que vous allez faire
avec du 10 gigas de ram derrière une
vague fluide yvette hyper fluide je
pense pas que vous utilisiez jamais 10
gigas de ram vraiment là-dessus quoique
je serais très surpris et point de vue
autonomie de batterie de 3200 millions
terreur qui se recharge ou 10 soit
directement en recharge sans fil soit
via un câble avec de l'usb type c'est
donc je vous disais l'absurde a surtout
trois provinces qui sont fait la toute
première promesse c'est vraiment le
point fort de ce produit son côté
vraiment esthétique le design qui est
irréprochable avec cette grande face à
l'avant ce grand écran qui occupe plus
de 93% de la face avant ça c'est
vraiment le gros gros gros gros point
fort ce smartphone
le deuxième point fort c'est la
performance pour moi la performance est
liée aussi ne serait ce qu'avec instinct
dragon 845 déjà couplé à 4 gigas de ram
ça fonctionne extrêmement bien
l'autonomie bien sûr ça reste à voir de
toute façon tout ça va être optimisée
d'un point de vue logiciel avec minuit
donc on se doute que ça va être une
vraie bête de compet ça va marcher la
suisse a fait absolument aucun doute
et puis la partie photo vidéo
connaissant la qualité du travail fait
par shiomi on l'habille notamment sur le
mit lui qui a pas très longtemps les
photos sont magnifiques
irréprochable donc à mon avis là dessus
aussi sur un mix 3 ça devrait aussi
fonctionner et envoyer du bois
d'ailleurs dit moi vous ce que vous en
pensez qu est ce que vous pensez de ce
mix 3 est ce que vous trouvez que chez
tommy a vraiment mis la barre haute par
rapport aux autres ce qu'ils sont en
train d'imposer un autre standard parce
qu'il pleut parce qu'avec ces parties
amovibles vous
ayez un grain de sable qui viennent se
coincer dedans que vous ayez des
poussières et que à terre même si ça
marche ça en rien peu ça je sais pas
c'est un peu le truc qui me fait peur
donc avoir effectivement à l'usagé
imagine que ils ont pensé que les
ingénieurs sont posées les questions
donc techniquement ça va être plutôt bon
à voir notamment lors des phases de test
dites moi vous ce que vous en pensez
est ce que vous trouvez que ce mx3 et
bien va dans le bon sens est ce que vous
pensez qu'en 2019
on va avoir des grands écrans sans
encore j'imagine toutes les personnes
qui étaient ce les encoches faire la ola
et à très très content vous marquez tout
ça en commentaire on reste connectés on
va tester d'ici quelques jours le
nouveau iphone 10 r on va tester le one
+ 6 t on va tester le google excelle
trois ans à tester le mail 20 he made 20
pro on va tester le sony y 3 ya plein de
tests qui a réduit les ordinateurs donc
vous invite à faire une seule chose
c'est à vous abonner à rester connectés
soyez ça je vous embrasse pour les soins
lourds et à très bientôt
ciao
[Musique]